one stop hoping for a completion of
anything in life
most men make the error of thinking that
one day it will be done they think if I
can work enough then one day I could
rest or one day my woman will understand
something and then she will stop
complaining
or I'm only doing this now so that one
day I can do what I really want with my
life
the masculine error is to think that
eventually things will be different in
some way
they won't
it never ends
as long as life goes on man needs to
learn to feel the present moment and not
hope for an unknown future
the challenge is to tussle play and make
love with the present moment
two never change your mind just to
please a woman
if a woman suggests something that
changes a man's perspective
then he should make a new decision based
on his new perspective
but he should never betray his own
knowledge in the intuition in order to
please his woman or go along with her
such an action will weaken both her and
him
they will grow to resent each other and
the crust of accumulated inauthenticity
will burden their love as well as their
capacity for free action
three
don't get lost in tasks and duties
whatever the specifics of a man's
purpose he must constantly remind
himself of the danger of losing himself
in an endless list of tasks
and refresh the spiritual aspect of his
life through regular meditation and
retreat
otherwise he risks becoming a mere
mechanical performer of Duties and
routine which leads to a loss of meaning
where inner Freedom suffers
a man must be able to stop find internal
depth and direct his attention to the
essence
not just superficial tasks
four
your purpose must come before your
relationship
every man knows that His Highest purpose
in life cannot be reduced to any
particular relationship
if a man prioritizes his relationship
over his highest purpose he weakens
himself
deserves the universe and cheats his
woman of an authentic man who can offer
her full undivided presence
5.
live as if your father had died
a man should love his father but be free
from expectations and criticism from him
a man needs to grow out of his shadow
become himself
and take responsibility for his
decisions and actions in order to be a
free man
6.
what she wants is not what she says
sometimes a woman will request her man
in plain English not to get him to do
something
but to see if he is so weak that he will
do it in other words she is testing his
capacity to do what is right not what
she is asking for
in such cases if the man does what his
woman asks she will be disappointed and
angry
the man will have no idea why she is so
angry or what could possibly please her
you must remember that her trust is
earned not by him fulfilling her
requests but by him magnifying love
consciousness
and success in their lives
in spite of her requests
seven
lean just beyond your Edge
at any given moment a man's growth is
optimized if he leans just beyond his
Edge
capacity and fear
he should not be too lazy happily
stagnating in the zone of security and
comfort
nor should he push far beyond his Edge
stressing himself unnecessarily unable
to metabolize his experience
he should lean just slightly Beyond the
Edge of fear
and discomfort
constantly
in everything he does
it is a process of self-discovery
where a man finds strength and wisdom in
his own Essence and unlocks potential he
had never even imagined
eight trust nobody
a man must be prudent Vigilant and able
to recognize true intentions before
placing his faith
trusting someone blindly often leads to
disappointment and betrayal
it does not mean completely isolating
himself or becoming cynical
but rather learning to trust his own
instincts and judgments
it's about Discerning who and what
deserves his trust and taking
responsibility for his decisions
trust is earned not given
nine
be willing to change everything in your
life
a man must be ready to dedicate
everything to his purpose
face or resolve the consequences of his
past actions
and then be willing to move on from this
particular way of life
he must be capable of entering a period
of uncertainty
not knowing what to do with his life
and waiting for revision or a new form
of purpose to emerge
these cycles of specific action followed
by periods of not knowing what the hell
is going on
unnatural for a man who is shedding
layers of karma on the way to realizing
his potential
[Music]
10.
she doesn't really want to be number one
a woman sometimes seems to want to be
the most important thing in her man's
life however
if she is the most important thing she
feels her man has made her the number
one priority and is not fully dedicated
or directed to Divine growth and service
she will feel her man's dependence on
her for his happiness
and this will make her feel smothered by
his neediness and clinging
a woman really wants her man to be
totally Dedicated To His Highest purpose
and also to love her fully
although she would never admit it she
wants to feel that her man would be
willing to sacrifice their relationship
for the sake of His Highest purpose
11.
don't use your family as an excuse
if a man never discovers his deepest
purpose or if he permanently compromises
and uses his family as an excuse for
doing so
in his core in masculinity become
weakened
his woman loses trust in sexual polarity
with him
even though he may be putting much
energy into parenting and housework
a man should of course be a full
participant in caring for children and
the household
but if he gives up his deepest purpose
to do so ultimately everyone suffers
12.
don't ever chase after someone
a man who constantly chases someone
often ends up with compromises and
dependence
which robs him of the freedom to be
himself
by pursuing someone and begging for
attention a man diminishes his own value
leading to a loss of self-worth
true self-worth is found when he starts
prioritizing himself understands his own
needs and values
builds his life based on his beliefs and
directs time and energy towards
self-improvement
13.
you don't have to please everyone
people like it when others give them
positive feedback and approve of their
actions
in reality
pleasing and trying to make everyone
happy only makes a man's life miserable
and attracts people who only want to use
him because they know that they will
always put their needs ahead of his own
everyone has things that they consider
important to them
if a man doesn't take time to determine
what is important to his life
it will easily find himself swayed to
focus on what is important to others
if we try to please everyone we will end
up pleasing no one
14.
if you don't know your purpose Discover
it now
without a conscious life purpose
a man is totally lost drifting adapting
to events rather than creating events
without knowing his life purpose a man
lives a weakened impotent existence
perhaps eventually becoming even
sexually impotent
in the end he becomes a passive Observer
of his own life plunges into a deep
emptiness and loses the ability to
self-realization and inner growth
foreign
nobody is coming to save you
a man must learn to save himself
and it has nothing to do with whether
people like him or not
they have their own lives to live
one must come to terms with this and
learn to live with it
people will move in and out of his life
and if he depends on them he will be
disappointed
a man should be responsible for his own
life eventually the best way to get your
life to where you want it to be is to
take control of your own destiny
[Music]
foreign